VI đê ô chia sẻ Chi tiết tuần tự các bước make up
để mà biến một cái gương mặt từ như thế này
trở thành như thế này
đây là thành quả sau BA ngày học make up cá nhân của Trinh
Cho nên
Trinh mới nói đây chỉ là mang tính chất chia sẻ thôi
nghĩa là mình sẽ share lại với mọi người tất cả những cái
tips và mình đã học được
gói gọn trong BA buổi
cái hành trình học bắt cóc cá nhân của Trinh
nó chưa có kết thúc đâu
nhưng mà Trinh cảm thấy là sau cái buổi thứ BA này á
thì Trinh đã có Kha khá những cái mẹo hay
và đặc biệt là những cái sản phẩm mà mình
siêu siêu tâm đắc
để mà chia sẻ đến với mọi người
nên là mọi người hãy a xem tuần tự từng bước
trước khi bắt đầu video thì Trinh chỉ có một cái disclaimer
nhỏ thôi
đó là mình không phải là một dân make up chuyên nghiệp
Cho nên là chắc chắn là sẽ có những cái Sai sót
nên là mọi người hãy đón nhận video này
với một cái tâm thế là
ờ giống như bạn của mọi người đi học make up cá nhân về
có cái gì hay ho
á xong rồi muốn share lại với mọi người thôi
chứ hổng phải là một cái make up tutorial nha
à nhưng mà Trinh hứa
là sau cái video này
thì chắc chắn là sẽ còn rất nhiều video về make up
khác trong năm 2
02 16 sắp tới
tại vì đây là một cái kỹ năng
mà Trinh
quyết định là mình sẽ rèn giũa nhiều hơn trong năm này
nên là mọi người hãy đóng chờ tiếp
thật là nhiều video make up trên kênh Trinh meo nha
dĩ nhiên là vẫn song song với những cái video về skincare
về sống thiết
về vlog về podcast
nên là mọi người nhớ
nhấn nút like cũng như là đăng ký kênh để mà tụi mình có
thể được gặp nhau ở rất nhiều tiếng nội dung khác nhau
ủa bái bai gì bắt đầu video thôi